Welcome back, I'm now going
to do a slightly harder
2-dimensional projectile
motion problem.
So let's start by drawing
the ground.
This is the ground and I'm going
to leave a lot of space,
so that we can do other things
with this chalk board.
Just draw the ground
like this.
And let's say I have something--
say I don't know.
Let's say it's a slingshot.
And it's angled up at-- let
me think of a good angle.
It has an angle of-- say the
initial slingshot's angle, so
just the angle at which it's
pointed is 30 degrees.
And I want to hit a target.
I don't know.
Let me just make up a number.
Let me say it is 100
meters away.
I want to know-- and I'm
on earth, so I'm
dealing with gravity.
I want to know, how fast does
the slingshots velocity in
this direction, in the 30 degree
direction-- I want to
know what this initial velocity
needs to be for me to
hit this target exactly.
So let's see if we could
figure this out.
Well, we don't know the initial
velocity, but let's
pretend like we do and maybe
we can break it up into its
horizontal and vertical
components.
Let's just do that right here
since we already have the
vector drawn out.
Actually, no, let me do it
in the corner up here.
So the first thing we want to
do is break it up into its
horizontal and vertical
components.
So this is our initial vector.
And it's vi.
That's our initial.
Let me call it vi,
initial velocity.
Its initial velocity in this
direction, in the direction of
30 degrees to the ground.
And we want to break that up
into its horizontal and
vertical velocities.
Or we could say it's along the
x-axis or the y-- whoops.
I want to be neat this time.
So I think it helps your
concentration, maybe.
I don't know.
So everything with horizontal
will be purple and everything
with vertical or along the
y-axis-- oh, whoops.
I just said that and I changed
my convention.
I'm malfunctioning.
That's that.
And we're ready to
rock and roll.
And this angle right
here is 30 degrees.
So instead of saying along the
vertical direction, let me
change this to along
the y-axis.
You can think of kind of the
traditional coordinate axes.
So what is the component of the
velocity along the y-axis?
Well we learned from the last
presentation, we could just
use standard trigonometry.
Opposite the vy, v sub y-- this
is v sub y right here,
this line right here.
Which I'm using the
wrong color.
v sub y over the hypotenuse,
v sub i is equal
to sine of 30 degrees.
Or we could say v sub y is equal
to the initial velocity
times the sine of 30 degrees.
What's sine of 30 degrees?
If you remember your 30, 60,
90 triangles, you maybe
remember this by now.
But sine of 30 degrees-- worst
case, use a table or a
calculator.
But hopefully, you know what
the sine of 30 degrees is.
It's 1/2.
So we know that my vertical
velocity-- last time I called
it v sub v.
This time I'm going to call it
v sub y because this is kind
of going along the y-axis.
My vertical velocity
is equal to 1/2
times my initial velocity.
That looks like an l,
I don't know why.
Did I actually say that an
l, a little while ago?
Anyway, that's v sub i.
So it equals 1/2 v sub i.
And oh, where was I?
My brain really is doing
something else right now.
Anyway, and this 1/2 is just
the sine of 30 degrees.
And what is my horizontal
velocity?
Let's get all the trigonometry
out of the way.
Well, my horizontal velocity,
doing it the exact same way
here, let's call that v sub x.
v sub x is equal to v sub i, my
initial velocity, times the
cosine of 30 degrees.
And if you remember your 30,
60, 90 triangles, you'll
remember cosine of 30 degrees
is square root of 3 over 2.
So v sub x is equal to v sub i
times the square root of 3,
all of that over 2.
So how do we figure
out how far?
Let's say we didn't know we
had to get to 100 meters.
How do you figure out how far
this projectile-- whatever's
coming out of my slingshot--
is going to go?
Well, we figure out how long
it's going to stay in the air.
And then, once we figure out how
long it stays in the air,
we can just multiply it times
our horizontal velocity and
it'll tell us how far it goes.
So how long does this thing
stay in the air?
For that we use our vertical
velocity or v sub y.
So we know that the change in
velocity-- let me switch back
to that other color.
We know that change in
velocity is equal to
acceleration times time.
And what I want to do is figure
out, how long does it
take for this object to kind of
get to its maximum height?
So it's decelerating
from this vertical
velocity, v sub y, to 0.
And how long is it going
to take to do that?
Well, let's see.
The change in velocity is 0
minus v sub y, which is this.
So it's 0 minus v sub y, which
is my initial vertical
velocity, the y-axis.
It's 1/2 v sub i.
I just wrote this
instead of this.
And that equals acceleration.
We're going to say minus 10
meters per second squared
times time.
I'm not writing the units for
the sake of efficiency.
And so, let's see.
If I divide-- so this
doesn't matter.
The 0 doesn't matter.
This and this, if I multiply
both sides by negative 1.
And then, if I divide both sides
by 10 I get t is equal
to 1/20 v sub i.
Or v sub i over 20.
Is this the total time of the
travel of the object?
Well, no.
This is the time that it takes
the object to kind of start at
a very fast initial
vertical velocity.
And initially it starts at
this velocity and then it
keeps decelerating until at some
point along its curve,
like here where it's vertical
velocity is 0.
And then it starts decelerating
or accelerating
downwards and comes here.
So just remember-- let me draw
the curve, actually.
Because I think that
might make it--
So the object is going to
take a path like this.
Whoops.
Something like this, right?
At this point, the object has
its full vertical velocity and
its full horizontal velocity.
And at every point as we get
higher and higher, gravity
slows down its vertical
velocity.
It slows down v sub y.
It slows down its vertical
velocity, but the horizontal
velocity stays the same.
And at this point, the peak
point, its vertical velocity,
how fast is it moving
upwards is 0.
And then its vertical velocity
turns negative and it starts
accelerating in the negative
direction or decelerating in
the positive direction
depending on how you
want to view it.
So this time tells us literally,
how long did it
take to go from this initial
vertical velocity to 0?
So that's how long does it take
to get to this point.
So the total time that
I'm traveling is
going to be twice this.
Right?
So let's say total time-- time
in the air, let me call it
time in the air.
That could be a good--
so time in the air.
We could call this time up.
And the time up plus time down,
and they're equal to
each other, is equal
to time in the air.
Time in the air is going to
be equal 2 times time up.
That equals 2 times this, which
is equal to 1/10 v sub i
or vi over 10.
So we know now how long this
object will stay in the air as
a function of its initial
velocity in
this 30 degree direction.
Now, we have to just figure
out, how far is this thing
going to travel?
And I think I'm running out of
time, so I'm going to continue
this in the next video.